hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and in this one i'll be
showing you guys how to shuffle around
the icons in your taskbar using windows
vista and windows xp using a piece of
freeware called taskbar shuffle
so as you heard me say before the name
of the piece of freeware i'm going to be
demonstrating today is called taskbar
shuffle and the name of it is actually
very representative of what it does for
windows vista and windows xp
this is a feature that's actually going
to be available in the release version
of windows 7 that allows you to move
around the icons in your taskbar that
actually isn't available yet for windows
xp or windows vista like i said so you
can go to the link in the description
which i'll provide which is
nerdcave.webs.com
and if you scroll down a little bit you
will see that it's called taskbar
shuffle and has full 32-bit and 64-bit
support as well as support for dual
monitors and ultraman dual monitor
systems
in order to get the software just scroll
about halfway down the web page and
select your version of your operating
system so if you have a 32-bit system
and you will know if you do if you have
four or higher gigs of ram that you have
a 64-bit system that's how you know
which version to start now if you are an
advanced user and you prefer to download
the taskbar shuffle without the
installer and install it manually you
can do that to the options below so
after you've downloaded and installed
and run the application you'll notice
something in your taskbar that looks a
little something like this taskbar
shuffle 2.5 if you right click it you
can actually go over the options and
settings in taskbar shuffle i'm going to
go ahead and demonstrate those now if i
click on settings you have a number of
options that i do recommend you take
number one is to start with windows
which will put in the windows startup
folder and always start without you
having to do it manually number two is
so that you can show the system tray
icon so you don't have to go in and
select the program files whenever you
need to change the settings you can just
go ahead and right click on the tray
icon and number three is that it checks
for updates at startup so when you start
up your computer and you might not have
the latest version of taskbar shuffle
you might have 2.3 you restart your
computer and you will know immediately
that you don't have 2.5 and it'll
download and install that for you so
let's get to the demonstration in order
to show you guys how to do this i'm
going to open up a number of windows
files and just have a number of things
in the taskbar that might appear to have
it clouded and crowded up that someone
might want to uh change the order of in
order to have their desktop more
organized now if you don't have the
benefit of dual monitors this is
especially helpful for those of you who
like to keep your windows organized and
have certain ones in front and behind so
say i was working with a microsoft word
document and an internet explorer
browser i'll use notepad for this
example i might want to have this one to
the left of the internet explorer
browser so right here see the notepad
document i can just drag this to the
left of the safari document and say i
want to switch this blue folder to the
right all you'd have to do is drag it
it's very very simple and incredibly
intuitive
not nearly as smooth as the windows 7
animations but you'll definitely get the
feel and know that you are moving around
the icons in your taskbar
so that has been a quick demonstration
of taskbar shuffle version 2.5 like i
said earlier the link will be in the
description for downloading and
installing this and the latest version
of the software will obviously be
available at that download link anyway
thanks for watching this tutorial guys i
hope you found it helpful and if you
have any other tutorial ideas or
requests go ahead and subscribe and
message me through youtube and i'll do
my best to answer your question with a
video or text response anyway thanks
again for watching i'll catch you guys
in the next video peace